le couronna virus continue de se
propager en europe
un premier cas de contamination entre
humains sur le sol européen a été
confirmé en allemagne
il l'aurait été après avoir rencontré
une personne venue de chine dans le
cadre de son travail
contrairement aux autres patients
signalés en europe qui ont quant à eux
été contaminée lors d'un séjour sur le
territoire chinois
le patient en question va bien cependant
il est toujours isolée dans un hôpital
de munich où il est placé sous
surveillance médicale
l' enquête sur la personne contaminée et
conduite avec la plus grande célérité
notamment dans son environnement
familial et professionnel qui ont déjà
été informés le risque de contamination
du patient reste très élevé
particulièrement dans son entourage
familial et dans les entreprises des
alentours qui ont évidemment été informé
en italie les passagers à bord d'un vol
en provenance de hong kong ont été
contrôlés hier par des professionnels de
santé lors de leur arrivée à l'aéroport
de milan
en france un quatrième qui a été avéré
ce mardi le gouvernement français a
annoncé le rapatriement de ses
ressortissants de la ville chinoise de
wuhan l'avion ce devrait être
normalement à one jeudi soit donc ça
veut dire qu'il part mercredi avec le
décalage horaire il arrivera jeudi
après-midi à roanne nous sommes en
constitution des équipes médicales qui
va accompagner cet avion l'objectif
c'est de pouvoir identifier sur place il
ya des personnes malades pour qu'elle
fasse l'objet d'une prise en charge
particulière et d'un transport
particulier et que nous ne mélangeons
pas
des personnes malades et des personnes
sans symptômes
les autorités japonaises ont également
annoncé ce mardi la présence au japon
d'un cas de contamination chez un homme
qui ne s'est pas rendu en chine mais
ayant véhiculé des touristes en
provenance de wall berceau de la maladie
le nombre de victimes du coronavirus
s'est aggravée et passe aujourd'hui à
132 morts environ 6000 cas sont
confirmés dans toute la chine selon un
dernier bilan des autorités